vivice-première ministre du Cana
- - Le courageux peuple ukrainin
sese bat pour lui-même et il se
babat également pour nous tous.
EnEn ce moment, l'Ukraine se
popositionne bravement comme
lele leader moral du monde libr.
LeLe courage des Ukrainiens a éé
sasalué encore une fois
auaujourd'hui par le gouvernemet
TrTrudeau - en marge de l'annone
dede nouvelles sanctions contrea
RuRussie. Depuis les derniers
jojours, de nombreux citoyens ds
orordinaires choisissent de
prprendre les armes en Ukraine
popour défendre leurs villes
faface aux Russes. L'une d'entre
elelle est Lesia Vasylenko,
dédéputée du parti Holos au
PaParlement de l'Ukraine et mère
dede trois jeunes enfants.
JeJe l'ai joint à Kiev
unun peu plus tôt.
LeLesia Vasylenko, députée du
paparti Holos au Parlement
ukukrainien. Bonsoir.
BoBonsoir Mme Vasylenko, merci
d'd'avoir accepté notre invitatn
dadans des moments extrêmement
drdramatiques pour vous.
- - Bonsoir. Je suis ravie d'ête
llà avec vous et de pouvoir
paparler sur la situation dans n
papays, dans l'Ukraine.
- - Oui, il est important aussi
popour vous comme député de donr
l'l'exemple, de prendre vous-mêe
leles armes. On vous a vu avec e
ararme à vos côtés. C'est
imimportant pour vous d'être
sosolidaire aussi du peuple
ukukrainien qui entend résisterà
l'l'invasion russe.
LELESIA VASYLENKO députée du pai
HoHolos au Parlement ukrainien
- - Tout à fait. C'est le peuple
ukukrainien qui est uni
auaujourd'hui contre le plus grd
agagresseur du monde, la
féfédération russe avec son
prprésident Vladimir Poutine qui
esest devenu fou avec le pouvoir
etet qui rêve de rétablir le grd
emempire russe. Et pour ça, il
veveut détruire l'Ukraine commen
papays indépendant et il veut
écécraser le peuple ukrainien
cocomme un peuple libre.
- - Avez-vous l'impression que a
momobilisation mondiale de l'unn
eueuropéenne, des pays de l'OTAN
auauto, de l'aide militaire quia
étété envoyée mais n'ont pas de
sosoldats sur le terrain peut
aiaider l'Ukraine à vaincre
PoPoutine?
- - Bien sûr que ça aide et ça
dodoit continuer à venir, mais e
totoute façon l'Ukraine si un ps
totout petit en comparaison à la
RuRussie et notre armée n'est ps
auaussi grande que les millionse
sosoldats que Poutine va déjà
enenvoyer dès demain en Ukraine.
EtEt c'est pour ça que les dépus
ukukrainiens font l'appel à la
cocommunauté internationale
d'd'envoyer en Ukraine des armé,
àà envoyer en Ukraine des avions
ququi peuvent fermer notre cielt
ququi peuvent protéger le peuple
ukukrainien et surtout les femms
etet les enfants des bombardemes
ququi viennent de la Russie et s
mimissiles qui sont envoyés déjà
mamaintenant non seulement de la
RuRussie, mais aussi de la
BiBiélorussie.
- - Vous êtes vous-même mère
dede famille avec trois enfants.
JeJe crois que vous avez un tout
pepetit bébé de quelques mois.
EsEst-ce que vous vous sentez
mamalgré tout à l'abri ou au
cocontraire, vous êtes inquiète?
VoVous avez peur de l'avenir?
- - C'est vrai, je suis mère de
trtrois enfants, ma plus petite
vava avoir 9 mois demain
etet c'est vrai que comme
totoutes les mères ukrainiennes,
j'j'ai très peur pour mes enfan,
popour leur futur, pour ma
fafamille. Mais toujours,
jeje suis déterminée à être là,
àà rester sur le terrain
etet combattre cette agression
ququi escale et qui devient de
plplus en plus grand chaque jou.
JeJe suis confiante. Je suis sûe
quque le peuple ukrainien
vava vaincre ce mal, ce mal
viviolent qui vient de la Russi.
- - On perçoit ici votre présidt
ZeZelensky comme un grand leade,
ququi assume très bien son rôle,
ququi n'était pas préparé pour
jojouer ce rôle-là à...
afaffronter, confronter Poutine.
OnOn parle de lui comme étant
lala cible numéro un de Poutine.
EsEst-ce que... parlez-nous de
ZeZelensky et de son courage?
- - C'est absolument vrai tout e
quque vous venez de dire.
ZeZelensky a vraiment pu
sese changer en un leader
vrvraiment très fort.
UnUn leader militaire
dadans un pays qui met la liberé
cocomme une plus grande valeur.
EtEt alors, il est là, à Kiev,
avavec son peuple, avec son arm.
EtEt il est prêt à être un exeme
popour aller jusqu'au bout.
- - Est-ce que vous croyez que
PoPoutine va mettre à exécution
soson plan d'éliminer le
prprésident Zelensky? Il dit
quque c'est la cible numéro un,
quque des mercenaires seraient
dédéjà en Ukraine pour exécuter
ZeZelensky. Est-ce que vous avez
pepeur de ça?
- - Poutine est devenu
ababsolument... absolument obséé
papar le pouvoir et absolument
obobsédé par cette idée
ququ'il doit vaincre l'Ukraine
etet le peuple libre ukrainien.
AlAlors il ne va s'arrêter à ri.
IlIl va utiliser des
mamanipulations, il va utiliser
lele terrorisme. Il va continuer
àà terroriser le peuple civil.
JuJuste maintenant, j'ai eu là
l'l'information qu'il a déjà
ararrêté 83 objets civils à
KhKharkiv. C'est une très grande
viville à l'est d de l'Ukraine,
avavec plus de deux millions
d'd'habitants. C'est la deuxième
plplus grande ville en Ukraine.
EtEt alors là, les gens innocen,
leles femmes, les enfants,
ilils sont sujets à des missiles
ququi sont envoyés dans leurs
ququartiers résidentiels.
AlAlors, si on a un homme
cocomme ça, qui donne des
cocommandes à ses armées pour
jejeter des bombes et des missis
susur des objets civils,
vovous pouvez bien imaginer
ququ'il peut faire du président
ukukrainien une cible.
EtEt puis, les mercenaires à
n'n'importe quel prix pour
ququ'ils l'assassinent.
- - Oui, plusieurs estiment
quque Poutine est irrationnel,
dédéconnecté et tout ça.
IlIl entreprend néanmoins
dedes négociations. Est-ce que
c'c'est un leurre, pour vous,
ceces négociations,
unune diversion? Ou il y a des
chchances de réussite?
- - Si j'ai bien compris la
ququestion, les négociations
sese sont passées aujourd'hui,
mamais alors c'était juste
lele premier... lala première ée
dede ces négociations.
OnOn va en avoir plus.
QuQuand il y a la négociation,
c'c'est que les diplomates
paparlent. Alors, les armes se
fofont silence à ce moment-là.
DoDonc, ça nous donne un peu
dede temps pour réagir et
réréhabiliter nos forces,
nonos armées, pour qu'on puisse
nonous défendre encore plus.
MaMais avec ces négociations,
onon voit déjà que les Russes
ététaient très... très... très
mémécontents du résultat.
OnOn peut le voir dans les
ininterviews, ils n'étaient
vrvraiment pas trop confiants
ququand ils parlaient, pas trop
ssûrs d'eux quand ils parlaient
auaux journalistes.
LeLes Ukrainiens, de l'autre cô,
ilils étaient vraiment trop for.
EtEt là, je comprends de ces
sisignes, de ces signes plutôt
pspsychologiques, en analysant
lala situation, que les Russes
nene savaient pas comment y
rerevenir à Vladimir Poutine
etet leur dire que les Ukrainies
nene vont pas céder et vont
totoujours continuer à se battre
cocontre cette agression
etet ce régime impérial.
- - Très bien, Lesia Vasylenko,
dédéputée ukrainienne,
mmère de famille, résistante,
memerci beaucoup de nous avoir
paparlé ce soir. Courage.
CoCourage et on se reparle.
AÀ bientôt. Bonne nuit!
- - Bonne nuit